hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alva
we are act words and now we're gonna do
the most snobby that was called choking
choking on ego we're gonna do the most
snobby thing actors can do talk about
actors acting badly we're gonna watch
them looper scenes acted so badly we
can't forget them embarrassment do you
ever like nervous pee no Cooper has peed
right out there Cooper is the lead
actress of the short film I was in civil
defense Red Rover all history short yeah
that's why you're here go check it out
today not as silly as we are coming
across cuz it's yeah that's how you
promote stuff you do I'm gonna go on The
Tonight Show and act all goofy and we
have lost viewers people have already
claimed these were reading each other
well that's all that counts are enjoying
each other a great performance can even
comment an impression on you ever see
this the Wickerman
oh yes cringe power blah non-playoff
quite as badly as a long-awaited
confrontation between judge let's move
what begins is a slow-burning war of
words this is good I do
[Music]
[Music]
yeah marching around with guns hangs in
the balance we need to stop and talk
about how annoying it is to crack
[Music]
over a decade later people are still
joking about Junior Will Smith Oh Mark
Wahlberg is a genius in this movie so
over-the-top his confrontation with me
[Music]
can't blame you for wanting to play a
science teacher you know I wasn't
playing a copper Brook Mark Wahlberg
doing a bad job of acting in a
forgettable movie
what no oh yes classics Carol what do
you do maybe you take a cue from Arnold
the nerdy teenager in troll 2 and do
something like this oh my god oh my god
educate you about the room now I conic
exchange
did you believe it sound like Cordia
yeah his co-star and friend Greg Sestero
the moment was inspire by virtually
identical line in rebel without a cause
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Wow okay Cooper hasn't heard of her
scenes of roommate's you're the first
person ever I noticed hasn't heard I've
never heard of look Cooper I know you've
been booking a lot with acting and
everything but if you want to become a
great actress
you gotta see some terribly gonna
forgive you is so rad you know what I
mean like that's just kind of that that
is the room I've covered so much Tommy's
chance I met Tommy why is it like the
whole point of the room was that it is
so bad it's good they still have
midnight screenings every week in LA for
decades have you heard of the disaster
artist for James Franco I'm so
uncultured for joke my god I would love
spill but I haven't even seen well the
remedy no I'm only giving you a pass
because the room is one of those is so
terrible it's great I love those from
beginning to end it is like filled with
quotes of just how bad it is you would
love this is gonna be such an unpopular
opinion but I feel like Lord of the
Rings is that to me know like I love
Lord erase let me just preface like I
love Lord of the Rings but some of the
stuff in it it's absolutely ludicrous
and insane like he'll be like oh yes
like now we're at the land of
like no one's to pay Oh Gretchen after
crack me up
but the cemetery it's interesting and
opening up the fantasy genre I love more
the rings but there's some like anyways
I'm gonna shut up until like I start
getting like you know harassed you will
see I will be I'm in control about it I
do want to say who knows to actors for
[ __ ] acting though because it's a
hard thing you're not always gonna be
perfect people are gonna judge you and
criticize you and that's just part of
the job I laughing with them and just
the sad part is a lot of time though you
might think you're doing alright you're
like and then you watch the footage back
in your life bad lot goes into what that
is I have the cameras yeah the
perspective of the camera that editing
there are actors I don't name it like
I've got to know enough people in the
industry specifically so I can't name
drums sir there are certain actors out
there who have gotten better in the
years but there's editors who have met
who have like yeah there's a lot of bad
takes just find a way a lot goes into
the hands of the director directing the
scene too yeah sometimes they'll give
you a direction for the beasts like
scream like I don't know like writing
plays of course
you G because you could be the doctor
you know people are in different boats
in this it's like well if you're such a
good actor you should be able to take
bad writing and make it good
what not all the time there's some times
where it's like I can only say certain
things certain ways to make it D safe
you know there's always so much you can
do something I think of great example of
that the Star Wars prequel that they
shoot that day so that's it yeah it's
just sad that he did Christiansen actor
he's a great actor Lee Portman great for
some reason they are terrible
like a lot of it comes down to the whole
production overall I don't know any
actors I'm like that actor is bad I
could be like that so formats wasn't
good but you're good actor yeah exactly
and you just or some people are like
okay that maybe that wasn't your best
but you're gonna get better when you're
an actor you you're so harsh on yourself
and the performance you give if you can
shift more into the my instead of like
you know what maybe that wasn't my best
and I could do this differently but I'm
gonna get ya and I'm gonna keep at it
because the worst thing you can do is
just throw in the towel and stop doing
it or stop trying to get better you know
to show it you know so you know I know
what a good actress is what about got it
the girl with the showgirls you know I'm
for it I don't think that was bad Oh
overreact ugly in a burger from time I
think if you watch that whole scene you
might agree with that's weird I've never
seen it so sometimes things out of
context make things look bad and then
sometimes that's out of context make it
look I will say very interesting choice
though because I probably wouldn't be
like yeah that's what she believed she
would do you know I've been a little
mathematic I mean I don't know I think
it's long you can I think with acting
you can pull off anything you want to as
long as it's truthful and it comes off
as truthful because people can pick up
on like acting that's why some people
can be high energy low energy it's just
whatever feels as long as you're
expressing what's it's real yeah when
you're acting you wanted to look like
acting when people right there all right
which is so high what but when people
are like oh you guys look like you're
being Nick Cage though he is he's the
master of being so bad it's good it's
you sometimes it's just actually good
yeah yeah yeah wicker man became
infamous for how terrible that the whole
movie is but his performance is so pop
look at his career though it doesn't
mean you have to
that's what I mean like people love him
because she can be awful but so
entertaining he's entertaining their
time for he's just great yeah fluctuates
so much but I think it's just the right
film you give the guy that's something I
think comes at two it's like are they in
the right film Mark Wahlberg into
happening that is one of the most
laughable that movies terrible every lie
about that month what no that is like
trying his best to like take it
seriously pretty bad he's like I cannot
take these lines seriously I do love
mark it's hard to oh yeah he's there are
actors who I think are consistently not
Graco I'm always amused by like the
allure Lautner in the Twilight I'm just
like I don't think he's doing a good job
but I am I love what he's on screen yeah
sure just exudes like combos that's the
funny thing about a lot of these actors
dude like just like I think early chant
Channing Tatum Taylor Lautner have this
capability of I'm just like they're so
confident like and so committed that
even when they're doing bad they're safe
don't know they're doing that they're
likeable even though you're gonna do if
not doing a good job and I think that is
a rare gift in it of itself where you
can be that confident that you don't
realize how bad it's like you need that
confidence to just be a whatever oh [ __ ]
it's not like dope kind of like I love
you and you still killed it because you
think you suck so like Congrats we on
the same page coupe heart hey guys
subscribe has a terrible oh yeah
subscribe to the real revenue per click
that notification about Paula coops on
Instagram and Twitter as soon as you can
I don't have a Twitter how are you gonna
make it in this business if you're not
out there a certain amount of sentence
I'd like to end this video with a
picture that day shout out to a woman
named Katie and Katie and I we have a
lot of really great conversations back
and forth she recently launched a movie
blog called through the looking glass
the water dot blog I read a good amount
of it so far and I'll tell you guys it
is great she is highly informative
efficient where their words wonderfully
like the best solutions of vocabulary I
can't even properly say it but here's
what I'll tell you guys it is absolutely
worth your time and as much as this bit
is going on I am sincere in the words
I'm saying I have subscribed to this
blog you guys should go do it too yeah
follow Katie Ann hot water not blog I
took a lot of work today